Speaker 1: t this you have to see this story
is an example of wasted activism and wasted
energy.
So many people in this country, in many countries,
but we're talking about this one, aren't involved
in anything going on around them.
They don't know what's going on.
They're checked out.
They don't get involved in anything in their
communities, whether the communities are their
immediate surroundings, the state, federal
politics, whatever.
Some people do get involved, but they get
involved pushing for all of the wrong things.
And that's what this is an example of.
In Yukon, Oklahoma, a school board meeting
was interrupted by anti maskers multiple times,
each with an outburst more weaponized and
delusional than the one that came before it.
Board members in Yukon voted to keep masks
on students for the rest of the semester.
Now, how long is that?
It's only another 11 days.
And I'm going to get to that in a little bit.
And it makes sense to keep students wearing
masks because none of the students are vaccinated
other than the Stret 17 or 18 year old senior
at the elementary school.
None of them are vaccinated at the middle
school and none of them are vaccinated.
And at the high school, almost none of them
are vaccinated.
There's going to be some flexibility on the
masking policy for the younger students.
But 50 anti maskers showed up at this meeting
and shockingly, some of them were given huge
rounds of applause for their anti mask rants.
Here is one such woman screaming that this
is not about covid, this is about control.
And the crowd goes wild.
They're cheering this insanity.
People are applauding what appears to be a
demonic possession, you know, heretofore I
did not believe in demonic possession, but
this video is making me second guess myself.
Maybe demonic possession is a thing.
This video almost made me believe in astrology.
It's so nuts.
Like if someone came to me and said, David,
I know you can't understand this video, but
I can.
This video is explained because this woman
is a Scorpio and Scorpio's behave like this.
This is so nuts.
I almost would believe in astrological explanation
because nothing else is making sense.
If you were watching, you might have seen
the police start to slowly approach this woman
as the rant was winding down.
Is there a silver lining of some kind here?
Can we say that, hey, at least she's showing
enthusiasm about education policy.
No, of course I'm kidding.
This is a tragedy.
I actually looked at the UConn public schools
calendar.
The last day of school is Thursday, May 20th.
After today, they have 11 school days left
and this woman and others are taking time
out of their days and going crazy about 11
days of masks in school for unvaccinated children
during a global pandemic.
Just imagine if they used their activism and
their energy for good instead of evil.
Imagine what good these people could do if
they were fighting for like anything other
than fighting against 11 more days of masking
in school.
We would live in a different world if that
energy.
Was put to something worthwhile, and if you
needed any evidence to support teachers being
paid more, by the way, this video would be
Exhibit A because these are the parents that
these teachers are dealing with.
Now, by the way, at one point in the video,
the woman also screams that her son is four
years old.
From what I've read, the mask mandate only
partially even applies to the four year old.
So she's out there protesting against just
11 more days of masks in the fall.
Probably there won't be a need for masks assuming
vaccination continues.
And as far as it applies to her four year
old, it's part of the day, 11 days of masks.
It's a tragedy of education.
It's a tragedy of culture.
And it is horrifying in absolutely every way
we can imagine.
And when we talk about, oh, wow, Biden needs
a new strategy for vaccinating people because
there's so many anti vaccines, it's the same
type of people that would show up and rant
like this on camera, about 11 days of masks.
It's a tragedy.
It's a real tragedy.
And we'll have some more clips from this deranged
and hairbrained meeting on our Instagram.
You can follow The David Pakman Show on Instagram
at David Pakman.
So you can follow me on Instagram at David
Pakman.
And we'll be back right after this.